silvano dîner
il est bien non il fallut
[Musique]
les manifestations au chili ces 26 morts
en seulement deux mois et demi
quoi
mais la création qui viennent et à
l'obstination
utilisant biolo massive et généralisée
d
m
pour brut je vous emmène donc au chili
pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi la
jeunesse là bas se révoltent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce mouvement de contestation sociale au
chili en fait il a démarré en octobre
2019 à cause de la hausse du prix du
ticket de métro à santiago
les étudiants et la jeunesse ont d'abord
descendu dans la rue pour demander le
retrait de cette augmentation et faire
pression sur le gouvernement
mais rapidement les revendications de la
population se sont transformés en lutte
contre la vie chère contre la corruption
et contre les inégalités dans le pays
j'en paie le tonique étaient maîtres et
la vie y était une réaction d'étudiantes
équitable atos atos de quel s ouvrir
leurs précieuses et que ledit sirène
avait mal les ventes d un match plein en
os et en flore pour que la rébéllion
tant bien que mal terrato contre l'aso
vert vis à vis une élite qui nous y
sommes prêts surtout son poste et pour
qu'elles sont fausses
non
paul eluard derrière moi des forces de
l'ordre ont bloqué l'accès aux rues
principales qui mène au coeur de la
ville
puis la place et en fait ils vont rester
là
jusqu'à qui décident d'eux
les aplats pas
son violon lauréate l'axé moratoire
[Musique]
non
sur place il ya maintenant plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes est en
fait c'est uniquement dans les rues
adjacentes qui a des combats avec les
forces de l'ordre
et c'est à chaque fois quelques
centaines de personnes qui se battent
avec eux
ça arrive à tout à l'heure ils arrêtent
pas d'envoyer des projectiles sont dits
police
vous pouvez ne va pas tarder à changer
ils sont en trombe
nous conformer de retourner leurs rangs
c'est parti c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à les traiter la puissance et ils
ont réussi à arrêter quelques personnes
avant de se retirer immédiatement parce
qu'il ya énormément de manifestants sur
l'avenue centrale
seuls les passionnés de trail a mano
gilles et si dans les plats de nouilles
fallou
c'est qu'il est toujours dit la vie
mello là il m'a la vierge et gustavo
jamais trop limité
bleach est une rigolote police
draghi a dit notamment jean à saint malo
mahler softphone vienne et social où la
riche et normé et c'est la validité ou
pas
lee burke est d'une beauté cicos folk et
soul hyundai on aurai l'occasion
yoaké dolls hltv notre public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut expliquer les manifestations
auxquelles on assiste aujourd'hui en
grande partie par la constitution de
1980 la constitution de la dictature
militaire du général pinochet
tout simplement parce que c'est cette
constitution qui a mis les bases du
système économique et social actuel qui
est fondée sur le néolibéralisme et qui
a largement privatiser et libéraliser le
système économique et social
et c'est cette jeunesse précarisée qui
se mobilisent aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
est née en démocratie et parce qu'elle
n'a plus peur de descendre dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
je ne m'écarte est un peu de la
manifestation pour rejoindre un gars que
j'ai rencontrés sur instagram il
s'appelle emile c'est un jeune
architecte et il participe lui aussi aux
manifestations mais à sa manière
donc on va aller le voir dans son
atelier vous allez vite comprendre
pourquoi
[Musique]
g
british en cours et sa photographie
[Musique]
m
et là ça va mieux
ils ont accepté
meiway
soit
opérationnel police et les autres des
seniors
ce cas
le soleil est en train de se coucher
mais ya toujours autant de monde
bah y'a même des feux d'artifice
je pense que les gens sont pas près de
partir
alors
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
si les jeunes sont en colère c'est
principalement contre le coût de
l'enseignement super dans le pays
et pendant la manifestation cette colère
allait elle est très loin
là clairement il ya des manifestants qui
ont pas conscience du danger on va
encore qui essaye de passer au travers
de l'université alors que les pompiers
sont en pleine intervention salée mais
eux aussi en danger en fait de devoir
aller les chercher pour leur dire ne
traversez pas
c'est bien de s'effondrer
les pompiers sont en train de maîtriser
le feu a presque plus plane
un tout petit peu on
chili c'est le pays où l'enseignement
supérieur et le plus cher de toute
l'amérique latine
il existe certes des bourses mais ces
bourses là sont en fait ne servent à
peine à couvrir les frais universitaires
il n'ya pas au chili d'enseignement
supérieur qu'ils soient gratuits même
l'université publique est payante et
elle est extrêmement coûteuse donc ces
bourses elles ne servent qu'à payer les
frais d'inscription
mais le coût de la vie lui même il
retombe encore une fois sur les familles
[Musique]
à
m
lens n'arrêtait pas de monter pendant la
manifestation et c'est au milieu de ce
chaos que j'ai rencontré adriel un jeune
chilien de 21 ans qui vient toutes les
semaines à santiago pour être en
première ligne de la contestation
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
à
paullo climat
un autre de revendeurs avaient le temps
après le one odeur à elle seule dans sa
valeur par la loi pour que dire
[Applaudissements]
à gaza
m
au moins 300 podcasts
il
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les radios locales agricole au cabinet
de gilles berhault non mais quand les
héros nationaux polonais
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]